I let the ftth council event in Europe
talking to Tim rings door who is the
managing director of JT global
enterprise Tim you've just start on a
big project on m5t th why FTTH well we
believe that this is going to be
absolutely essential for our economic
growth in the island for the future this
has been backed by the government
heavily in terms of a digital jersey
program so they're trying to encourage
more ebusiness into the island to
diversify the economy so the the fiber
to the home is absolutely critical we
believe for new business entering jersey
what exactly are doing tell us a bit
more about the project ok this is this
is literally taking all of our copper
out of the network and fiber directly to
the home because we believe that
fundamentally if you don't take the
copper out there's always going to be a
bottleneck and at some point in the
future you're going to have to take that
out so we've got the capability of doing
that our predecessors invested heavily
in our duck network so actual fact
pulling our fiber into the home is much
easier than we thought it's not without
its problems but we we've we're moving
forward very quickly with that and what
this will mean that every household will
be able to get at least a gigabit to
their home and more in the future
fantastic that's amazing and what's this
going to be in for the economy well as I
said this we believe is going to drive
the future economy we we fundamentally
believe it's going to grow our business
because people demand for higher
bandwidth is going to grow we've seen 3d
TVs the smart TV smart devices you know
we can't predict what's going to happen
in the future and really this is the
underpinning access network that we
believe is going to be absolutely
essential for the future and we're
investing in it ok well thanks for
talking to us Tim so Jersey great
holidays great broadband
you